Yes, no, it's not regular hydro peroxide. It's food grade that must be diluted. So it follows a recipe that's on
Mercola's I haven't on there. So
There is no previous lift to compare. This is the first. So send me the MRI so I can look at that, please
Many patients choose to an operation to remove the tumor and often is
Is a part of alopathic standards of care once the tumor is suspect lymph nodes and suspect lymph nodes are removed and there's no visible
Cancer left in my case colorectal tumor. I understand my next step possibly
Of circulating to ourselves instead dealing with circulating to ourselves and stem cells. I'm not that interested in prophylactic chemo approach
Stop there a second. So what when a surgeon does a debulking of a tumor. Let's say they debulk the tumor. Let's say it's a colon colorectal tumor or something
And they remove that section of the colon and they say that they feel like it was
Completely intact that they have spread beyond that. There's no visible spread via a pet scan examination. There's no visible spread via
MRI or CT scan
Blunt test look normal. Let's say it's a breast cancer. They remove the breast. You do a vestectomy. There's no visible spread. There's no metastasis that's present
Therefore your quote-a-quote cancer-free or quote-a-quote no evidence of disease
Why would you know people struggle with why would an oncologist then recommend prophylactic chemo be on that point?
Why are you asking me to do chemo?
when um
you
Would you say that there's no weapons of disease? Would you say you've got it all with the surgeon was
Confident that they got it all
because the oncologist understands that
Long before even you are diagnosed with cancer your tumor was giving it off
Circulating tumor cells or what are called cancer stem cells
So those still are present and in order for our cancer to be picked up
A pet scanner or a CT scanner MRI it has to be three to five million cells large
So the person may already have metastasis that
Doesn't mean that it's gonna turn into full-blown cancer at the at that place might be a couple hundred thousand cells large
And your immune system it might be effectively killing it
But it might not so could chemo help with prophylactic chemo help in that case the answers honestly yes, it could
But a lot of people don't want to do that because that can also knock down your body and can knock down your immune system and can cause all sorts of other issues that
maybe are not
appropriate for a person who's struggling with cancer can't i try to kill this in other ways
Yes, that's what you're that's why you're doing the right. That's why you're doing all these other things
Finish a person question as such what blood tests or other tests do you recommend to determine
The extent of these cells the circulated tumor cells and the cancer stem cells
In the body and what are typical connoisse clinic approaches to reduce or eliminate these circulated to ourselves and stem cells
Um, what are possible ways forward to deal with this from your holistic perspective
So that's the benefit to me that is the that is the benefit of a natural approach. You how do you
You know take a cancer that's trying to set up hope but raise a family
tumor cell circulating in your body trying to set up
Hope would raise a family elsewhere other than the primary tumor site aka. How do you prevent metastasis?
You have to stimulate that person's immune system do everything you possibly can and use
Use frequency technology using rife technology rife technology is not gonna just hit the primary cancer
It's gonna hit that cancer anywhere it is in the body
Well, if rife really works why didn't it take care of the primary tumor and just make that disappear?
Well a lot of cases it does and a lot of people it does
But lots of times remember you're dealing with a tumor that's multiple centimeters large
Um, your immune system to try to get in there and kill it. Those are millions and millions and millions and millions and millions of cells
It's difficult. It's difficult. That's why I've always said from the very beginning of ever doing cancer work
It can be beneficial to debulk a cancer
And by debulk it means to remove surgically removing or chemotherapy
removing a good portion of the cancer so it gives
The immune system a better chance to kill small tumors maybe even smaller cancers than our
able to be detected on a PET scan smaller than three million cells large
Your immune system thinking your immune system can it how can it kill a
Uh, a cancer that's that's two million cells large. Is it easier to kill that or kill a cancer that's
40,000 million cells large
You know think of it as it's what's gonna be easier pretty common sensical, right?
So if we took away a lot of the burden the larger mass of the tumor surgically if that's possible
That it's easier for an immune system to plead up those other things. So um, I would highly
Suggest that you continue your natural approaches as best as possible
To answer the question as um what blood tests can be done to determine the extent of these other tests
Uh, those that report to do a circulated tumor cell test would say you should run circulated tumor cell tests
There are blood tests on the mark that are circulated tumor cell tests
Why don't you advocate for circulated tumor cell test Dr. Conor's the reason is is that
It's only measuring the amount of circulating tumor cells in the blood sample
Okay, you might show zero
Circulated tumor cells
That doesn't mean that you that you have a given off circulated tumor cells sometime in the past which everybody with
And that those kids those cells have set up home
But are trying to raise a family in the liver and in the lungs and in you know some other organ
um, you can't measure that so the only way they're
Had you measure the extent of circulating tumor cells in your body? No
The only thing you could measure uh, is the extent of circulating tumor cells in that blood sample at that given time
Which to me gives you really no real
Data that can really help you if if it's zero you have zero circulated tumor cells. Wow. That's great. Well
Yeah, that's better than having circulated to ourselves in the blood
But it still doesn't give you any data
Uncirculated to ourselves that have
migrated to other tissues and are starting to replicate or have yet to replicate in other tissues
That are city dormant in your liver that are city dormant in your lung that doesn't give you that data
And there isn't any way to measure that there's no medical way to measure that until
The cancer that circulated tumor cell
And starting to replicate and is replicated beyond three billion cells large then it'll be picked up on a pet scan
um
Even if it starts to replicate in your immune system is keeping it at bay
There's no way to measure them. So um
Probably the best way to measure
this point um if pet scans are clean MRIs are clean CT scans are clean um
How do you monitor this patient then well to get follow the oncologist's recommendation to get follow up MRIs or CT scans or pet scans
um that are reasonable to you
And be
Measure tumor markers do a tumor marker tests. Well, I've had that and my tumor marker tests
Don't show positive. So but so well good. Let's just keep that monitor. That's a cheap inexpensive non invasive way
To measure if you know something jumps up
um
And if you never showed
Positive tumor markers with your cancer that doesn't mean
That a metastasis wouldn't show positive tumor. So
That's the best way to measure it as far as a natural approach holistic approaches
Everything you're currently doing remember you just removed the largest burden now your immune system can focus on any cleanup
Data any cleanup information
Um thinking the burden that was on a person's immune system when the tumor was large
Not to say that we haven't had people and lots of people have you know
I have um experience of the tumor shrinking even if it's large
But some people it doesn't and then debugging it is the way to go take that burden off the immune system so that
Now you can focus on getting rid of this stem cells and such